We're asked to graph y
is equal to 2.5 times x.
So we really just have to
think about two points that
satisfy this equation here,
and the most obvious one
is what happens when x equals 0.
When x equals 0, 2.5
times 0 is going to be 0.
So when x is 0, y is
going to be equal to 0.
And then let's just
pick another x that
will give us a y that
is a whole number.
So if x increases by 1, y
is going to increase by 2.5.
It's going to go
right over there,
and I could graph
it just like that.
And we see just by
what I just said
that the unit rate of change
of y with respect to x is 2.5.
A unit increase in x, an
increase of 1 and x, results
in a 2.5 increase in y.
You see that right over
here. x goes from 0 to 1,
and y goes from 0 to 2.5.
But let's increase
x by another 1,
and then y is going to increase
by 2.5 again to get to 5.
Or you could say, hey, look,
if x is equal to 2, 2.5 times
2 is equal to 5.
So this is a legitimate
graph for this equation,
but then they also
tell us to select
the statements that are true.
So the first one is
the equation does not
represent a proportional
relationship.
Well, this is a
proportional relationship.
A proportional
relationship is one
where, first of all, if
you have zero x's, you're
going to have zero y's, where y
is equal to some constant times
x.
And here, y is equal
to 2.5 times x.
So this is definitely a
proportional relationship,
so I'm not going to check that.
The unit rate of the
relationship is 2/5.
So I'm assuming--
this is a little
ambiguous the way
they stated it.
I'm assuming they're saying
the unit rate of change of y
with respect to x.
And the unit rate of change
of y with respect to x
is, when x increases
1, y changed 2.5.
So here they're saying when x
changes by 1, y changes by 0.4,
2/5 is the same thing as 0.4.
This should be 5/2.
5/2 would be 2.4.
So this isn't right as well.
The slope of the line is 2.5.
Well, this looks right.
Slope is change in
y over change in x.
When x changes 1, y changes 2.5.
So change in y, 2.5,
over change in x, 1.
2.5 over 1 is 2.5.
And you could also
see it looking
at the form of
this equation. y is
equal to-- this is
the slope times x.
So that's right.
A change of 5 units in x results
in a change of 2 units in y.
Well, let's test that idea.
We know when x is 0, y is 0.
So if x goes from 0 to 5,
what's going to happen to y?
Well, y is going
to be 2.5 times 5.
2.5 times 5 is 12.5.
So y would not just change 2.
It actually would change 12.5.
So this isn't right.
A change of 2 units in x results
in a change of 5 units in y.
Well, we see that.
A change in 2 units of x results
in a change of 5 units in y.
That's exactly what we
graphed right over here.
These two points show that.
So this is definitely true.